hi there Steve Kaufman here so today I'm
going to start answering some of the
questions that I received when we had
our little competition tell me what you
would like to talk to Steve Kaufman
about if you had a 30-minute Skype
session let me say as well that we're
trying to schedule this online session
with our winner Daniel Candido I think
his name was so
Jurina of our office is gonna try to set
that up it won't be next week because
I'm busy with visitors but we'll be
doing that but in the meantime I thought
I would try and address some of the
other questions that we receive and I'm
gonna do them in no particular order our
offices put them together in a list and
I'll simply go through them and if you
have additional questions please don't
hesitate to send them along so actually
I can see this if I want a coaching
session with Steve I would ask advice on
how to improve my English from
intermediate to to advanced okay first
of all the difference between
intermediate to an advanced is sometimes
difficult to define when we are fairly
advanced in a language like intermediate
2 we are often more conscious of our
shortcomings than the people were
talking to who think we speak very well
and we feel that there's stuff that we
didn't understand or things that we had
trouble saying so that it's a very fine
line so that's point number one
so don't be too harsh on yourself point
number two the only way you can improve
in a language whatever your level is to
continue to engage with the language and
to challenge yourself so if you're an
advanced or at least intermediate to you
aren't improving English you have to
read more and more challenging material
you have to read novels you have to read
you know do as much reading as you can
listening
you can and eventually of course
speaking in order to speak well you have
to speak a lot you know I am a great
proponent of input based learning and
for example in my Arabic I'm not going
to bother trying to speak until I have
at least 3,000 words but I know that
eventually in order to speak well I have
to speak a lot those languages that I
speak the best are the languages that
I've spoken the most but also the
languages where I have read the most and
listened the most so now on the positive
side when you are at the intermediate
two level you are now at a level where
the language is enjoyable you can in
fact read on a variety of subjects watch
movies engage with people you can do all
these things that are you know going to
improve your language and you can do
them as part of your slow process of
improvement so in summary don't be too
hard on yourself you're probably better
than you think and the only way you can
move along to reach a more advanced
level is to read more listen more and
speak more and write more so just keep
on doing more of the same that would be
my answer to that question second
question was how do I prove my listening
abilities in Japanese I've been studying
for eight years I often have this
question about listening comprehension
listening comprehension is in some ways
the most difficult skill and I remember
living in Japan I was doing business in
Japanese I was reading a newspaper in
Japanese but when I was watching
Japanese movies lots of it I still
couldn't understand it just takes a long
time for the brain to get used to this
new language and I think the only way to
improve our listening ability is to
listen but I find that when I listen in
languages where I'm fairly advanced and
I keep on missing certain parts I have
to I want to have the text I want to
listen to content where I can also read
and look up the words and of course I'm
using link I save the words and I might
see them again
in other words you have to as I say so
much in language learning is a matter of
training the brain so if you just let
the language go off in the background
and you're not sort of zooming in on
those phrases that you have trouble
picking up maybe you won't get them you
might get them on the third or fourth or
fifth time but you may not so therefore
I think it you should make it a practice
for example if you're you know very
advanced in Japanese get yourself an
audio book I know there are audio books
in Japanese I have some and in fact
there are audio books of you know 90s or
early twentieth century literature I
have some there are also political you
know the NHK takes I don't know if the
texts are available you have to go out
there and find material where you have
both the audio and the text and then
listen to it and then read it and if
you're using links save words and
phrases so that you gradually train your
brain it's a gradual process it's not a
matter of a while I give up I'll never
get any better
you have to deliberately work it work at
it next question here I would ask
another burden otherwise more
efficiently and how to improve my
English even well I think this is more
of the same whatever your level you have
to put that time and effort into it
there's no and it is a slow process and
maybe one more how would I best way to
transfer reading skills into speaking
skills in Chinese I mean it's all the
same all of us we may be more advanced
in some skills than other skills so if
some people in fact are better at spoken
Chinese and nada written Chinese but
then you have to put more effort into
those skills that are lacking
speaking in Chinese conversation Chinese
is difficult because Chinese has
somewhat fewer sounds it has the tones
and also unfortunately Chinese people
from different parts of China pronounce
Chinese in different ways so you may
find it easy to speak to someone from
Donbas and you may not understand
someone from Shanghai or from even from
Beijing who may be speaking something
very close to Mandarin so there again
what can I say you know continue your
reading do a lot of listening but see if
you can find people with whom to speak
to speak well you have to speak a lot
you have there is no there is no
shortcut you can't go from just
listening and reading and bingo all of a
sudden you can speak it doesn't work
that way you build up your basic
capability in the language your
vocabulary your ability to comprehend
your sense of the language but then you
have to activate it and to activate it
you have to speak and you have to speak
a lot all right and maybe that last one
here how to work on my pronunciation now
okay pronunciation first of all let me
say that I have interacted with
non-native speakers of English who spoke
English extremely well who used words
well who express themselves with
eloquence and had a fairly strong accent
and it never bothered me
pronunciation only becomes an issue if
people can't understand you when people
hear an accent but they hear someone who
speaks very well I think they're almost
more impressed I love listening to
people with a French accent or a
Japanese accent or whatever who just
used the language well so your first
task is to use the language well and to
understand well because there's nothing
worse than talking to someone who seems
like not to understand what you're
saying now next question the
pronounciation itself I've always said
the most important thing is intonation
if you can get the intonation of the
language right a lot of the
pronunciation the individual sounds will
fall into place also if you get the
intonation right that's very pleasing to
the ear of the native speaker it's more
important in my view than the individual
vowel sounds or consonant sound that you
might pronounce somewhat more you know
in a French manner or a Spanish manner
Japanese or Chinese or Russian matter
that's less important get the intonation
right so how do you work on that
well if I were doing it if I were
deliberately working on I tend not to
work on pronunciation because I listens
to so much that and I don't try to speak
at an early stage so that I listen to so
much like I've been listening to so much
Arabic in Arabic is bouncing around in
my brain when I eventually go to speak
it I'll have a bit of a head start on
the pronunciation because I've been
doing so much listening but if at a
certain point I wanted to improve I
would take a short initially a sentence
or a paragraph at link and I would
listen to it listen to the voice and
then I would try to read it or even from
memory say it focusing entirely on the
rhythm and the intonation of the
language and I would just work on
getting that intonation right because
with the intonation for example in
Chinese if you get the intonation your
tones your individual word tones are
going to improve rather than trying to
focus on say the tone of an individual
syllable or the pronunciation of an
individual word if you can get the
intonation of the phrases and the
sentences I think the rest of your
pronunciation is going to improve
so my advice on pronunciation is hey
don't worry about it too much be focus
on intonation the intonation of phrases
and sentences and you can do that by
having a text in front of you listening
to it and then reading it or going from
memory and then try and imitate the
intonation and you may want to record
yourself and compare yourself to the
native speaker if you if you
mispronounce the artwork don't worry
about it focus just on get the
intonation okay that would be my advice
and with that I've handled a few of
these questions and I will go through
the rest of them and there's quite a lot
of them and if you have additional
questions please don't hesitate and if
you like these videos please subscribe
so bye for now
[Music]